this is Eric thoughts first visit to
Berlin in years a trip in decades past
he would not have been free to embark on
his time trapped in the infamous Colonia
Dignidad cult has left him traumatized
not least because of the torture he was
subjected to Karunya Dignidad remains
something that I can never forget
attitudes towards it have improved today
and has the will to investigate what
happened but the experience is there and
will stay forever
Sartre was among those who openly
challenged Chilean leader Augusto
Pinochet critics of the dictator were
swiftly rounded up and Colonia Dignidad
was among the regime's torture centers
where they were held the commune had
been founded by German immigrants in
1961 the cults leader Paul Schaffer
brainwashed adults and sexually abused
their children isolated from the rest of
Chile the inhabitants were essentially
reduced to slave labor while the
colony's basement saw appalling
atrocities
electroshock or Andy the electric shocks
never ended and for a long time without
them even asking questions globby I
suppose the point was to break any last
remaining emotional or physical
resistance are accountable in last week
at the invitation of the German
government together with other victims
many of them accused the authorities of
West Germany and then unified Germany of
turning a blind eye to the reports about
Colonia Dignidad German Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier has acknowledged
that mistakes were made
he bought soft had the Seulong of the
embassy failed to insist that German
nationals which the majority of colonias
residents were be allowed to speak to
consular officials the Foreign Office
and the Embassy lost their way in a
conflict of interests maintaining sound
relations with the host country and
protecting human rights gink often bar
on boat surfed the organ to young fellow
not the apology victims had been hoping
for but the German government will now
be declassifying files on the colony
Eric thought is happy to see Berlin now
taking these steps
here to see my value what the minister
said I think it's a new start on this
front not all of the victims invited to
Berlin see things that way however
what's missing is an undertaking to
compensate us I left the colony a decade
ago and we're still waiting what we're
back in Manoa and they're waiting for
the perpetrators to be punished hot mud
hop was Paul Shaffers number two in
Colonia Dignidad also head of the
hospital he said to have used
psychiatric drugs to pacify residents in
2011 the Chilean authorities sentenced
top to five years in prison for aiding
and abetting the sexual abuse of minors
but he'd already fled the country for
Germany his citizenship here has
protected him from extradition so far
very little progress in terms of
prosecutions in Chile and practically
nothing in Germany some of the
perpetrators of Colonia Dignidad are
fugitives who have been sentenced in
Chile people like Hartman hawked have
fled to Germany to escape justice while
investigators here are not doing enough
in my opinion
born in Chile ever taught now lives in
Austria his entire time in Colonia was
as a prisoner of the Chilean secret
police the least he hopes for is that
one of the culprits from back then shows
remorse you man you go on besides if
just somebody would say sorry for
something the jimothy only in chill dick
with a Shawn that would mean a lot to me
if they give after the farm if you think
we all deserve something like that
Colonia Dignidad is now known as Villa
by Vieira and that rebranding as a
Bavarian village includes bizarre
attempts to attract tourists with events
including a Munich Star beer festival
the colony is currently home to around
150 people with the perpetrators and
victims living as next-door neighbors
nothing neither a museum nor even a
commemorative plaque now reminds
visitors of the horrors this place
witnessed